Here, the dimensions of the rectangle are 8 inches by 4 inches. Great thinking
if you found these numbers. We begin solving by starting with an equation for
the perimeter and the equation for the area. We know the value of the perimeter
here. The perimeter is 24 inches, so we can replace P with 24. For the area
equation, we know A equals l times w. We can replace it this value of A with
its numerical value, 32. Now that we have these two equations, we want to solve
this one for the value of l. So we can use substitution to solve. We'll divide
each term by 2 to get 12 equals l plus w, and then we'll subtract w from both
sides to get 12 minus w equals l. And now, here comes the substitution. We
replace l with this expression, 12 minus w here. We multiply each term in the
parentheses by w to get 32 equals 12w minus w squared. Then, to solve this
quadratic, we move these terms to the opposite side of the equation to set it
equal to 0. We factor this quadratic by finding factors at positive 32 at sum
to negative 12. Those factors are negative 8 and negative 4. And finally, we
set each factor equal to 0, so w can equal positive 8 or w can equal positive
4. We know the width should be the shorter dimension, so that will be 4 and our
length would be 8. Our unit of measurement is in inches on all sides and we can
quickly check to verify the perimeter and area for our problem. If we add up
all the sides around the object, we'll get 24 inches. So yes, that checks with
our original problem. And if we multiply the length times the width, 8 times 4
equals 32 inches squared, which was our original area. Now, it's okay if you
didn't get all of this, but hopefully, you made your way at least to the
factoring. Great job if so.